And it's my pleasure to be here today with doctor Mark Ketta.
Koski.
It was a brief introduction.
Mark is president of the longevity company forever labs and it was the first to
demonstrate that micro RNA functions as a communication molecule between brain
tumor cells.
He has a medical physicist with extensive experience developing stem cell
therapies for neurological disease and injury.
He's come to Google today to talk about rejuvenating bone marrow and it's
significant opportunity to combat aging.
He also just might live forever.
A Dr Mark Ketta.
Koski everyone
[inaudible]
thanks John.
Thanks for coming today.
Um,
so yeah,
my name's mark.
Had a Koski.
That's,
that's my first birthday there.
Um,
and I'm the president of forever labs.
Uh,
we're a longevity company as John said,
and we're based in Ann Arbor,
Michigan.
I'm currently are out here in mountain view though cause we're in the summer
class of,
of y Combinator.
And so we've been,
but we've been operational for about a year and a half.
Uh,
we started,
um,
my aunt.
Yeah,
I bank.
And so what we do is we,
we bank adult stem cells and then cryo preserve them for future therapy.
And we also are working on developing some of these therapies,
uh,
for which to use these cells in.
And so I'm going to,
I'm going to kind of talk about what we're doing and why we think it's a good
time to do it and why we've,
we've made decided to,
uh,
disrupt our lives and,
and make this happen.
Um,
and also,
but I'm going to talk about kind of the greater context that we're doing with
it.
And I think,
uh,
I powerfully believe that there is a change coming in in healthcare and how we
provide medical services.
And I'm going to talk about what I see happening,
what's happened,
what's happening now,
and where things are going
in addition to that.
So I've kind of structured this talk,
uh,
as,
as kind of like the arc of my,
my own scientific career for the last 15 years because what I've been doing
largely reflects,
uh,
my thoughts on what should be done and,
and,
uh,
so I'm gonna talk about that.
And so that's kind of like the the,
and then at the end I just wanna kind of white wax philosophical about,
uh,
about the space in general and what it means to,
to actually have long been a longevity company.
So first,
first I want to talk about is uh,
an issue we don't like to think about too much.
So how do we die
after?
So after about Middle Age,
in middle age we start to die of,
of,
of causes that are quite similarly related.
They're called age related diseases.
And so that's heart disease and the number one killer in cancer,
which is a number two,
if you put them all together and stroke and,
and lung disease,
dementia and a,
all these there age related diseases and all of these diseases,
what they have in common is they are caused by a dysfunction at the cellular
level,
which leads to dysfunction at the tissue level,
which leads to systemic failure.
And so you,
you know,
you have some like a blood clot that goes to the brain and it builds up a blood
clot,
goes the brain and you have this,
the stroke.
That's a,
the atria,
the disease or in cancer you have cellular to some lunch and that leads to
tumorigenesis and then you get a develop this cancer.
And we've actually,
so when I was putting this data together though,
I noticed something interesting that traffic accidents,
can I surprise me?
15 to 24,
25 to 35.
Um,
traffic accidents are really leading cause of death in the youth.
And I think that if we can get cars that drive better than we do a,
then we're going to have some serious improvements in health care for youth.
So somebody should work on that.
Um,
but so we die by age related disease.
Now we have the privilege to do that because I'm going to move to some,
so this is,
this is cancer incidents in the United States.
And you can see as you get older,
your chances of getting cancer go up dramatically.
And we know why that is.
That's because when you get older,
you've accumulated more,
uh,
just mute,
more mutations,
more damage in your cells,
and they start to build up and you get a cascading effect.
And what also happens at this time in life is that you start to have a decline
in your immune function.
Your,
your immune system does not survey for cancer,
for a tumor jet for two third pre cancerous tissue.
And as well as it used to.
And the immune system plays a very important role in preventing camp tumor,
genesis and cancer.
And interestingly,
so in the last hundred or so years,
or if you go back more than a hundred years ago,
rather,
um,
cancer,
it wasn't something many people got the chance to experience because we would
die of infection or we would die in childbirth.
And cancer is a fairly new disease in the sense that we have through antibiotics
and,
and better,
um,
early healthcare.
Uh,
we've been able to live to this point where we start to fall apart and we
develop cancer so we fall apart.
Okay.
And that's age related disease.
So what are we doing about it?
What are we doing about it right now?
Well.
So what,
what does health care right now,
if you look,
I looked in the Oxford English dictionary and health care was first used.
It's pretty new term.
It was used by the US government,
a pamphlet called a health care for children and about 1940 and,
and then the deer definition that I found in the Webster Merriam Webster
Dictionary was the maintenance and improvement of physical and mental health,
especially through the provision of medical services.
So the maintenance,
improvement of physical health,
mental health.
So I take issue with that.
I don't think that's a very good definition for healthcare,
at least as we practice it.
So,
and I'll tell you why we spend in the United States,
90% of our healthcare funding goes towards the treatment of age related disease.
So not any percent goes towards this point where we have a dysfunction and it's
actually,
I would argue,
we spend our money on the restoration of health,
medicare spending in United States.
And to illustrate that Medicare spending in the United States,
30% of Medicare spending goes to just 5% of the business beneficiaries that are
going to die this year,
um,
in any given year.
So 30% goes to the 5% that is dying in that year.
And,
and of that 30% of the Medicare for spending a third of that actually goes to
those,
those people in those patients in the last month of life.
And so what I think what more accurately describes what health care's today is
an attempt to restore health that's been lost and not a very rational attempt
because the more desperate the fight gets more desperate,
the battle,
the more money,
the more resources we plow into it.
And it,
especially in the last month of life,
when,
when a problem's almost retractable,
that's when we put the most resources into,
into this.
And that,
I think is what healthcare is today.
I think this definition actually better defines what healthcare is going to be
in the future.
I say that because we are developing technologies that are enabling us to work
with our biology in very subtle ways to actually do maintenance and improvement
on a cellular level.
And by doing so,
we're able to prevent the dysfunction of cells.
Um,
and we're also able to actually sometimes undo some dysfunction in cells and
restore the health on the cellular level.
And if you can do that,
if you can do that,
well then you don't have system failure or you can prevent systems failure and
you have an economic incentive to put money up front where you can do a lot of,
of good with little money.
And the Axon economics are absolutely gonna just drive this transition from,
from this disease treatment,
a type of healthcare that we have now to a maintenance of health type of
healthcare that we're going to have.
And so,
like I said,
I'm going to talk about my experience and how I've come to this,
how I've come to the,
you know,
where I'm at in federal lab.
It's why we're providing the service we are.
And,
and,
uh,
with my own scientific,
you know,
kind of story.
So it starts 15 years ago in 2001,
I had just graduated,
I got my bachelor's in physics and I was a little burned out protocoling fortran
and I wanted to get my hands dirty and I want to do some science where I love to
work with my hands.
I'm going to do some science where I could,
I could,
you know,
do some more experimental stuff.
And at that time I was introduced to a,
a scientist,
he was a professor of physics actually that turned biologist,
but he's also,
I was a,
is a very prim preeminent stroke researcher.
His name's uh,
Michael Chop and you know that lab,
he was the vice chair of neurology and Henry Ford,
Henry Ford Hospital,
Michigan and Detroit.
And I sat down with him.
He was looking at bringing on graduate students and he told me what they were
doing,
their lab is,
they were working on new treatments to first stroke,
new therapies for stroke.
And you're gonna have to bear with me cause I'm talking a bit about stroke here
because,
but stroke I think as as is an age related disease a lot do I say do stroke is
like how we use to treat it,
how we're trying to treat it now and how we can treat in the future.
Um,
applies to other age related diseases.
This is my own personal experience.
This is how I got to where I'm at today.
And so,
uh,
Michael,
he described me the current state of stroke treatment and that was there was one
drug,
one FDA approved treatment for the stroke.
It was a pro approved a five years prior to that.
It's called TPA.
And it's simply just is an enzyme.
It's tissue.
Plasminogen activator is simply the enzyme that dissolves the clot.
When you have a stroke,
87% of strokes are ischemic and you need dissolve this clot because the clot
blocks blood flow to the brain.
The brain needs a lot of energy and a lot of oxygen and dies very quickly.
And so tpa simply says it dissolves the clot.
Um,
and,
and to save the brain.
But TPA has a very serious too serious limitations.
One,
you've got to get it quick because you're spraying dies quickly and to tpa
because of its mechanism,
action can turn a ischemic,
a blood clot stroke into what we call hemorrhagic stroke where you get a brain
bleed and you've just exacerbated the problem.
And at that time in 2001 about 5% of patients are eligible actually be who
helped by this drug.
We're getting it.
And so this is the third leading cause of death.
And you know,
we had,
we could maybe help 5% of people that were having this.
Um,
and so what Michael was working on,
he told me is they were working on could they treat stroke after this phase.
We knew at the time we,
we know that that after he brings has injury,
it does heal itself to an extent.
There is a production of new neurons,
there is new blood vessel growth,
there is induction of neuroplasticity,
which means you're the neurons that do exist.
They start to make new connections and try to compensate for the loss.
And Michael said,
well,
if we can,
if we can improve that,
if we can improve that natural ability for the brand to heal itself,
then we have something that we could at least treat everybody that survives a
stroke.
And,
and the way they did that,
the way they were looking and starting at that time was they were looking at
stem cells.
And I'm sure everybody's heard of what a stem cell is,
but the definition of what stem cells,
it's just,
it's a cell that can do two things,
two important things,
one divide almost indefinitely.
I don't know if you've heard of,
uh,
of telomeres,
but at the end of your DNA,
after the salad vision,
your DNA will get shorter and shorter and shorter and a normal cell until the
cell malfunctions and dies.
But stem cells express an enzyme called telomerase,
which will extend the telomeres on the cells and they can divide almost
indefinitely.
And the other,
the other important thing that stem cells can do is they can define multiple
tissue types.
Um,
and I'm the one going to talk about,
I'm gonna talk about one stem cell quite a bit is the Mesenchymal stem cell of
the bone marrow and the Mesenchymal stem cell can,
can differentiate into bone and cartilage and muscle.
And um,
and so that's what makes it a stem cell there.
But there's a third characteristic that doesn't define stem cells but something
they generally have and that is that they have a powerful influence on the
tissue around them.
Um,
typically what that means,
especially in this context of injury,
it means they can,
they can promote healing,
they can regulate inflammation so it's appropriate and they can also,
they can recruit,
you know,
new blood vessel growth.
Um,
and so that's why they were looking at stem cells to improve the healing after
stroke and assigned cell stem cell they were looking at was this Mesenchymal
stem cell.
And actually I'll say we are looking at,
because that's what I decided to join the lab and get to work with this and a
Mesenchymal stem cell was,
we chose that for two reasons.
One,
you have a lot of them.
The adult body has a lot of Mesenchymal stem cells.
They're in your bone marrow.
Three easy to collect.
They're very easy to expand to large numbers,
therapeutic numbers.
But two,
they have a very powerful influence upon tissue around them.
Mesenchymal stem cells make copious amounts of,
of soluble factors that will decrease inflammation and promote regeneration.
And so that's why we were looking at can we use these cells to treat stroke
after it happened?
And we started and we did these experiments where we found we could grow,
hasn't came old,
hasn't kind stem cells and treat mice or rats with them.
And we got what we thought were pretty amazing results.
So we treated these animals just intravenously,
just injecting the Mesenchymal stem cells into the bloodstream after the stroke
and those animals that are treated.
Uh,
so after they had the stroke,
they have this,
you know,
motor deficits,
they would lose function and they would also have cognitive deficits that we
could measure through a battery of tests.
And these cells,
these animals that are treated with the cells,
they would recover much more readily and they will recover,
uh,
much.
Uh,
to a greater extent.
Then those animals that weren't treated in,
in,
in coincident with that we would look in the brain and we would see an increase
in new neurons.
Um,
after the treatment,
um,
we would see a increase in synaptic plasticity even far away and the
contralateral part of the brain,
this Mesenchymal stem cell treatment,
um,
improve the plasticity and learning of the injured rat and we'd see a blood
vessel growth,
smaller scar in the brain.
So this was,
this was exciting.
We had this,
um,
we developed this thing that maybe we could treat more and more people with and
other labs took interest and started to do this and actually repeat our results
and,
and um,
and things move from there.
Okay.
So thanks for bearing with me on stroke because I'm almost out of it.
Yeah.
15 years later now.
So this is 15 years later and at last count there's 14 registered clinical
trials using mesenchymal stem cell therapy for the treatment of stroke in
humans.
And I highlighted too,
that I think are particularly interesting.
One is this top one,
it's going on at Stanford or this doctor Gary Steinberg.
He's taking the cells and his objective directly into the brain around the
damage issue area and he's,
there's two things interesting with the trial.
One,
there's a,
there's people in this trial that got the treatment and they had hemi paralysis,
they had loss of limb function and they actually were gaining limb function.
The thing that makes it very interesting that to me is that he was treating
these people sometimes six to 12 months out after the stroke happened and
that's,
that's really chronic and often it's thought,
you know,
you can do,
you can do some physical therapy and speech therapy and whatnot to try to
recover,
but 12 months out,
what you have then is often thought to be what you're going to get back and to
be able to affect a change to that point is it's pretty stunning.
And so they're moving on to the next phase.
And then this third,
this,
there's other trial here is going on in South Korea and I highlighted it for two
reasons.
One,
it's phase three,
so it's pretty far along.
Um,
but the other is that,
uh,
they're doing something interesting with the cells,
which kind of illustrates what can be done.
So one thing we found early on in our,
in our work is that we found if you prep the,
uh,
Mesenchymal stem cell,
if we,
if we introduced the Mesenchymal stem cell to an injury area,
it changes its behavior.
And it upregulates is production of a lot of these factors that,
that have pro healing.
And they are actually in there in a human trial.
What they're doing is they're taking the cells and they're treating them,
they're growing them out,
but at the same time,
they're exposing them to the plasma of the stroke patient that they took them
from and to prep this Alison kind of advance them and get them ready for the
treatment.
So I thought that was pretty cool.
Um,
and,
and this is actually not just stroke.
A lot of labs recognize the therapeutic potential of Mesenchymal stem cells and
been using them for the treatment of
age related diseases like heart disease and bone and cartilage,
neurological disease.
Um,
even other,
I mean other neurological diseases like Alzheimer's,
um,
we use it for traumatic brain injury too.
It's pretty good effect.
There's a trial in Houston doing that.
Um,
and so that's to say Mesenchymal stem cell therapy has really advanced and it's,
it's really given options where there were a few
well
but there's a problem.
Okay.
So and it's some problem we recognized pretty early and others did too.
So we have these cells,
they've got this therapeutic potential but
your stem cell numbers and function decline as you get older.
So 10 years from now you're going to have less themselves and you have,
and you've now and the ones that you do have are have less therapeutic potential
whether it's going to have a decrease in function.
The graph here on the left demonstrates this one study was looking at just
counting the number of circulating blood progenitor cells and this vasculature
vascular progeneter cells in,
in,
in the blood and just counting the number.
And that decreases with donor age.
There's an interesting study that's kind of related.
The University of Messina and in Italy they took 80 year olds and they just
counted the circulating stem cells in their blood and just kind of them.
And then they revisited those individuals seven years later and they actually
found that the number of stem cells,
the concentration circulating in the blood was predictive of whether or not that
individual is going to be alive seven years later.
And they said that that might be an interesting predict biomarker for.
Um,
the graph on the right here,
we've got mesenchymal stem cells and we're just looking at the bone building
potential to sell.
As I said,
they can build bone,
they can become bone building cells and,
and that decreases that potential decreases with age.
Here's another showing Mesenchymal stem cell,
um,
decline with age.
This is just looking at perforation of the cells.
Uh,
this top line,
this graph is just using,
growing.
This is just growing them in culture and seeing how fast,
how readily they cliff rate.
And you've got two to 12 year old child cells and they grow quite readily to
great numbers and you can expand the [inaudible].
They're exponential growth.
You can get a lots and lots of cells,
like really you can,
I mean a pound of cells from,
from that so many.
Um,
and,
but if you look down at the bottom line,
uh,
that's those older donors,
that's a 60 to 70 year old donors and they don't grow as quick and they don't
grow as much.
And you can see after like nine passages,
they just stop and we call that senescence.
Um,
you know,
if,
if somebody gives me,
whether it's a mouse or a rat or a monkey or whatever,
human cell,
Mesenchymal stem cell,
and they've given me two different ones and they say they're for different ages.
I can tell them really quick which one's which,
because it's pretty stark striking the difference between the cells,
uh,
functionality.
And so that's bad.
But this,
this,
this turns to Senescence here,
these were these old one stop.
It's actually thought to be supposed to be beneficial thing too,
because these cells have become damaged over time and a stem cell,
because of its ability to divide infinitely and to influence the tissue around
it,
it can be a risk factor for cancer.
A lot of cancers are caused by stem cells gone awry.
And so it's thought that this is an essence.
What these cells will do is it'll slow down and they'll turn themselves off,
often will just commit suicide.
But often that actually they'll just kind of hang out too.
And because they're just kind of given VAD and they go be like bad vibes,
the tissue around it.
And actually,
um,
it's a,
it's a problem.
Um,
so,
all right,
so I was,
I was working in this stroke lab.
We had this great therapy and it was,
you know,
maybe it's moving the clinic,
but there's this problem,
the stem cells that we're using are,
are declining and more than you're more likely to have a stroke.
You all at your stem cells have,
have gone downhill.
And so,
uh,
my buddy that was a colleague of mine and he's our chief science officer,
Dr Ben Bowler and I,
we'd often talk about this stuff and we said,
well,
we should do something about that.
That's,
you know,
and there's something that you do really easy.
You just like take them and send them forward in time.
You just take young cells and you send them to your future self and,
and,
and use them when you're old and that's easy and you don't even need Deloreans.
You just do what we call is a Hetero chronic transplant.
Don't mention medical oriented.
So we do as a,
it's called a Hetero chronic transplantation.
And so he just private preserve the cells.
We've been doing that for a long time.
It's a matter of course in the lab.
Um,
I've grown cells that are more than 40 years old.
once at liquid nitrogen,
the cells are biologically inert as,
as you freeze them carefully and as long as you of them carefully,
the time in between,
it doesn't matter so much.
He actually,
you start to think about background radiation if you want to keep them for a
long time.
Um,
and there's been successful bone marrow transplants,
one of the oldest stem cell therapies there is with cells that were frozen for
more than 20 years.
So okay,
we can,
we could take ourselves our young cells and freeze them for old herself.
Um,
I want to talk to people about this one thing.
The question that always get so is,
well,
why not allergenic?
Why can't you just take someone else's young cells and just treat yourself?
You don't have to even worry about that then.
Well,
the answer to this,
this is immunity is crazy.
And the,
the,
the complete answer to this is that if it's very complicated,
but,
but a general answer to this is that your immunity is a unique and you have to
overcome obstacles to,
to do this allergenic transfer.
Now there's a,
on your six chromosome,
there's this big cluster of about 250 genes that is called the Hla or the major
histocompatibility complex.
And what it does is it says,
this is me.
And if another cell expresses different,
it says it's not me and your body tries to kill it.
If you want to regrow,
regenerate tissue,
if you want to incorporate tissue longterm in your body,
um,
you typically need your own cells or you need to modulate the immune response.
And often that means immunosuppressants.
Well,
so if you've heard in bone marrow donation,
what they're doing is they're donating these hemopoietic stem cells that are in
the bone marrow.
And there what you'll do is,
and those actually are cells that give rise to immune system and what they'll do
is for the recipient has to actually get the immune system wiped out.
And then they will put in a new one and from the donor and they tried to get a
perfect match,
but even then it runs a very high risk.
Um,
and it's very dangerous because that immune system that comes in might recognize
the recipient as the foreign body.
And then you get this thing called graft versus host disease where the,
the donors marrow attacks the recipient.
Um,
and it's,
it's very deadly.
And so we'll take immune suppressants to prevent that same thing in Oregon
donation.
Um,
they people take immune suppressants and like I said,
the immune system is very important for the prevention of cancer.
And those people that have received our recipients of organ donation,
they have a much higher incidence of cancer.
Uh,
you might remember those,
like in France about five years ago,
there was a first successful face transplant,
well that,
that woman actually,
she died just recently of multiple cancers.
She was on very high on powerful immune suppressant.
Um,
so,
so it's not an ideal situation,
but to be honest,
there's some ways you can get around it.
And there's some ways that we sometimes,
so the Ma and I'll talk about the Mesenchymal stem cell because there are about
one third of trials using mesenchymal stem cells are allergenic like this.
And the reason was thinking the thinking was,
well,
they don't express what this major histocompatibility complex number two,
and they don't really tell the the recipient's body,
hey,
the where we are foreign and so you can get this therapeutic effect.
Um,
but what we've was more come to light and recently is that they actually,
when you put them in the body,
they do start to express this,
this thing.
And they get to us.
They don't realistic,
a big immune reaction,
but they do get wiped out.
They do say disappear and um,
kind of evidence of this.
So the,
the second,
the,
the trial at Sanford,
uh,
that I mentioned,
they're actually using allogenic cells and put it directly in the brain and they
look two months later in the cells were gone.
Um,
I'm not sure if they were the patient's own cells,
if they'd still be there.
That would have to be tested,
but they were gone.
And it's,
it begs a question where they have a more persistent,
um,
could they have even got more if they,
if they use cells of the,
of the patient's arm,
you just me.
Um,
but definitely if you want to replace tissue,
if you want to get new tissue,
you need your,
your own cells are by far the best.
And it's not so simple as just deleting this piece of,
of DNA.
Uh,
there's a lot of non coding genes in there that are regulating things and it's,
there's,
there's actually jeans in here.
They're important for,
for infection and other,
other functions.
So nothing is generally that simple.
So that's why not allergenic.
All right?
So,
hmm,
we talked about this and you could save your young cells,
but
you're a trained is age related disease,
right?
And you say a young cells and,
um,
to treat something catastrophic happens later in life.
But you know,
I've been to start a point that maybe this,
maybe this stroke,
you know,
we know this,
maybe the stroke isn't just because it doesn't,
we can,
we can attack it earlier.
Like,
so when I was actually,
when I was talking to our CEO,
when I was putting this slide together and talking about tpa,
now we still have,
tpa is still the only one FDA approved drug for treat,
for treatment stroking United States.
So this is 21 years later,
and it's not for a lack of trying.
The,
the n I n d s budget was a national institute.
Neural disorder instruct budget last year was 1.7 billion.
Uh,
it's,
um,
but he said yes.
He was like,
well,
what do we do?
And I said,
just don't have a stroke.
It's a,
that's what you do.
And honestly,
I think that that's what a bed and I,
my colleague and I were starting to think like,
can we prevent this?
Can you get,
get ahead of it.
And there's a lot of similarities in age related disease and age related disease
is not a fact of all life.
I think a lot of people just think life,
death,
you know,
this is just part of the natural process,
but they aren't two sides of the same coin.
Amoeba is another singular cellular organisms.
They don't necessarily age.
So an Amoeba,
when a device,
you don't have a young Amoeba and an old Amoeba,
you have to have me.
But as they're the same age,
they just maybe just get around the problem by just fixing damage faster.
It happens.
They can fix the wear and tear of life faster than it occurs.
Um,
and so let me,
it was really just like an ageless organism.
Hydras um,
are also,
they're interesting.
They're a multicellular organism.
And there's no increase in mortality,
uh,
with a hydro as,
as time goes by and they're actually interesting.
There is just chalk full of stem cells are almost like stem cell trees.
Um,
and so there are these creatures that,
that don't experience aging,
but multicellular organisms,
they tend to,
but it does beg the question.
And this is something that we were often talking about.
Do,
what does this have to happen?
This is a client happen to happen.
If we could,
if we could do like the Amoeba and we can do maintenance on a lowest,
they'll sell you a level and it could,
we prevent the aging process in humans.
We do this in our cars.
I mean classic cars not far from our office in Anarbor.
I can go to Henry Ford Museum and I can,
I can take a ride in a model t that was built more than a hundred years ago.
Um,
so anyway,
we're kicking around this problem.
We knew the cells that had to be,
had to be saved for later because they were losing this important properties.
Um,
and then,
uh,
this is 2012.
We got this call,
we have this call for grants from the NIH.
This is grant,
this call for applications.
And um,
when you're a researcher,
you write a lot of light,
a lot of grants,
um,
that's your life.
And,
and um,
it's a brutal process.
Uh,
when you writing grants,
because half of the grants used submit aren't even discussed.
They're not even,
they don't,
they get to the,
uh,
this,
you get it back and says,
not discussed and so you're going to get feedback.
You don't even know what was bad or it was good.
They just don't even,
and so it's almost like you spend a month writing the grant,
doing research,
and then you just pick it up and drop it in the waste Bin and they move forward.
That's what the feeling.
Um,
so anyway,
so we got this grant and this grant was funny.
It was,
had give us your craziest idea.
You don't have to write a big,
a big proposal,
just a short one or two pages.
It was like just your craziest idea.
You're thinking of something that you wouldn't write a proposal on.
Otherwise we want something that's,
you know,
kind of all bang.
And,
and what we also saw,
Ben and I,
we often laughed at acronyms that scientists use.
Um,
because we'll often,
like you'll give acronyms to genes or proteins to explain like the first thing
that we saw it too.
And then everybody finds other things that it does.
And it confuses everybody because they,
they,
you know,
they named it after something,
some functionality.
Anyway,
this grand was called Eureka and that's actually an acronym.
It was,
um,
it was extraordinary.
Um,
oh Geez,
ex ex extraordinary,
um,
unconventional research,
enabling knowledge acceleration.
And,
and we laughed at it.
One thing,
there's,
it's not even grammatically correct.
Like you can't accelerate knowledge.
You can accelerate the acquisition of knowledge,
but like that's like throwing a book,
you know,
it just like,
it doesn't make sense.
So,
so,
so we were like,
well,
that's great.
Let's do this idea.
Let's,
let's use young cells and we'll try to trade.
He aging itself,
like we know that there's a decline in the cellular niche and the,
and the bone marrow niche.
And So said the stem cell niche.
And so we said,
what if we just simply take these young mscs and we take genetically mine
genetically match mice,
which you can do.
And we take young ones and we come to old ones and will they,
will they have increased health span?
Um,
if we,
if we prevent the decline of the Niche,
William increased lifespan.
And so we submitted this proposal to this Eureka grant and probably you probably
not the best idea.
We decide to come up with a worst acronym and we called it battery.
We call it bone marrow,
autologous transplantation,
helping the old regain youth.
And if you're a student of history,
a lady bathroom was a homicidal,
a Hungarian Nobel woman that when bathed in the blood of a young victims this
to,
to live forever.
So,
so
you can tell her starting to get burned out at this point in my career.
Um,
so,
so whether by our,
our,
we did actually,
we didn't actually get,
um,
and it was discussed,
let's do it.
Um,
and so,
but we didn't get the grant,
we didn't get the grant,
and maybe that was her sense of humor that prevented it.
Um,
but interesting.
Yeah.
One of the things too,
I'll never forget the review of that grant because one of the,
one of the reviewers said that our,
our idea didn't use enough technology.
And I thought,
you know,
what does that even mean if you take something that you have,
if you take everything you have and you use it in a new way,
that's the definition of innovation.
But they weren't interested in it.
I guess we have to shut up for lasers on it.
Um,
so in researching this grant though,
we came across something and that was really interesting to me.
So at the University of Texas,
in Arlington,
there was a group and they asked a very similar question.
They were looking at bone,
but they said,
what if we use young bone marrow cell mesenchymal stem cells and we transplant
to these two,
told her mice,
um,
how would they fare?
Would they have,
because they're looking to osteoporosis,
the loss of bone density over time.
And they said,
would this prevent the onset of osteoporosis or slow it down?
And they found indeed it did slow it down.
Um,
when they,
when they did this and these are genetically matched mine,
so it's kind of like a twin kind of transplant and um,
but it's,
there's a surprise serendipitously.
They also found that the mice,
that they transplant them to live longer and they did an age match,
um,
transplant as well.
They took old mscs and give him the old mice and they didn't live longer.
And so that said,
the youthfulness of the cells was,
was it was important to this,
to this effect and that really started to,
to eat,
eat,
chew away at me.
I was like,
this is something that,
um,
you know,
we should be pursuing.
This is something that's worth looking into more.
And then a year after we got the grant rejected,
there was another group that just said whole bone marrow,
young,
whole bone marrow and transplanting it to older genetically match mice and those
mice,
they reported live longer.
And,
and that was about it.
I was,
I was on a phone call with,
um,
some business minded friends,
our CEO Steve here.
And,
um,
I said,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not mad.
I didn't get the grant,
I'm not mad,
I ain't get the first paper,
but I'm turning 40 this year.
Um,
I want to store myself.
It's like I want to put myself aside.
And he said,
well,
that something I'd like to do too.
And we started to talk about it and one thing led to another and we,
so we met with an orthopedic surgeon,
um,
who's now our chief medical officer award,
ween orthopedic surgeon.
And he said,
you know what,
I'm already taking bone marrow.
He's like already doing pulmonary.
But they do is they'll take it out and we'll concentrate it and then we'll
inject it at the site of injury or after our surgery to promote healing.
And so we realized there was an on ramp for this idea.
And now,
so what we're doing,
here's Steve.
He's,
he was the third person to bank.
That was number two and number one was our CSO cause he's hockey player.
And here's Steve.
He's like,
just,
yeah,
I had it done.
Um,
it's really,
really pretty minor.
And so our,
our,
what we do now is we credential,
um,
orthopedic surgeons,
sports medicine and plastic surgeons generally.
And the do this,
this bone marrow aspiration and collection is,
it's,
it's pretty simple.
It's outpatient in and out in 15 minutes and you got your stem cells.
But we keep those.
But,
um,
and so we,
we,
we did this,
we went operational and we're 15 months ago and now we're in,
we're in seven states.
Um,
and so there's more to it though.
So we're not just collecting,
we're actually doing the experiment we wanted to do.
We're running that right now.
Um,
we're doing the heterokaryon lung transplantation of,
of old,
of young mscs to older mice and we're going to see if it improves their health
span because we're neurologist.
Um,
we're looking at also their cognitive health as well and we're going to see if
we can slow the onset of cognitive decline.
Um,
and so it's really,
I'm,
I'm excited to find out whether we can make this work and if we can make it
work,
can we improve upon it?
One of the issues when you're dealing with,
with,
with therapy is you always have dose and delivery.
You need the therapy to go where it needs to work,
not where it doesn't and you need it to go there.
And a therapeutically effective dose.
And I mentioned,
you know,
there's a number of really interesting technologies or working on rejuvenating
cellular cells and the cellular level.
And when we had the cells outside the body,
we have an opportunity to work on them,
which are much higher fidelity.
And we're also pursuing this that we can not only just take out the cells,
young cells and giving you a older,
but in the intermediate we might be able to improve upon them,
um,
incorrect damage.
Um,
so that's,
that's where we're doing.
That's where we're headed.
Um,
and so on a personal level,
I made the transition,
you know,
about a year or so ago from a lab grant funded scientists to,
to,
you know,
somebody starting a longevity startup and,
and you know,
it was brought on by what I was seeing happening and,
and,
but it was also brought on by something that's very,
I feel very powerful.
This is,
this is a problem.
I,
we share a problem that we don't talk about even though it's like,
it really defines so much of our culture and that problem.
The way I see it is that we have what it feels like in a mortal consciousness.
But we have a mortal body.
We feel like we should live forever,
but our bodies don't.
And
my grandmother in three days,
she's going to turn 92.
I've got one left,
his grandparents and um,
she said to me like a year ago,
she said,
mark,
I feel like the same person I was when I was 18.
I feel like that the,
and she said,
where'd the time go?
She said,
you know,
what happened?
And to be honest,
this is the first year that she couldn't come to our family cottage.
Um,
and she's,
she's not because she doesn't want to.
It's,
it's,
it's because of the Kleiner health.
She wasn't able to go,
she wasn't able to make the trip and there's been no decline in her desire to
spend time with their loved ones.
There was no decline in her desire to enjoy the life that you had.
And so I'm personally moved by this problem.
We all are.
I think,
I think we,
we've,
especially as we've as a culture of experience,
age related disease more,
I think what we've done is we've told ourselves stories to,
to,
to come to deal with it.
We kind of have to,
it's a,
you know,
these are therapies to deal with this,
this thing is facing us.
Um,
and we can,
sometimes we conflate,
I think the wisdom of age,
uh,
with,
with the,
what,
what age looks like and,
and,
and the experience of like the pigs and pains of age.
And I,
I,
you know,
if age,
we call it the golden years,
but if aging was a product,
nobody would buy it.
Like if you are,
if you're given the option in any given year,
and someone said,
hey,
how about you can either agency or a little more or you don't have to,
you'd be like,
I don't have to,
I won't,
I won't use this here.
Um,
if you take it year to year.
And,
um,
interestingly,
so we're out here.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're very various in Michigan and we have operations like in North Carolina and
stuff and we're out in the valley where we talk about what we're doing and this
problem that we see and we get a lot of like,
cool,
awesome.
Yeah,
knock it out.
Like,
um,
and put in Michigan and some of the places in their lives,
we often get like,
people like,
you know,
different looks,
people said,
well,
hey,
you're there checking.
And so there has to be,
there's going to be a shift that has to occur culturally too as this happened.
Um,
but I don't want to,
I don't want to be unrealistic.
It's a hard,
it's a difficult problem.
And as a physicist,
you know,
turn biologists,
I see it as like through thermodynamics.
You can't take a system and really turn that system and its and its surroundings
to its initial state.
You got entropy to deal with.
And so there's disorder whenever you're trying to create order DNA repaired kind
of easy clean repair or not so easy.
Um,
and,
and what you have to deal with,
if you're,
if you're trying to revert a system so complex to an earlier state,
you have to deal with,
um,
what,
what you've created in that process.
You have to,
all of the complicated click has complexities and,
and then really like almost the exhaust of the,
the process and that that is going to create Bob skulls on his path.
And you know,
um,
for instance,
so CRISPR is a technology that many people are aware with this new gene editing
technology.
Well,
we just are starting to uncover that CRISPR,
when you use it in an organism,
there might be some other interactions and leading to some,
um,
it might be not just editing the gene you wanted to edit.
You might be editing a bunch of other genes.
Uh,
mother nature is extremely efficient.
She doesn't use the same,
the one thing for only one,
a one purpose in biology is generally a lot of different,
uh,
s loops,
um,
and insured mechanisms and,
uh,
and that,
that makes this a difficult problem to address.
I,
we're good at what we're gonna do first is we're going to slow the aging process
before we're going to start to turn it backwards.
Um,
for that reason I strongly believe,
but at least to to great extent.
Um,
but so we've delivered,
we've,
we've developed this,
what was,
you know,
it was like kind of a hack,
right?
Not enough technology.
Um,
we're,
we're freezing youth.
Um,
so we can have a leg up.
I,
you know,
worst case scenario,
you've got a young cells to treat age related disease,
but,
but what we really want to do is his first attack,
the decline in the stem cell niche.
And then from there,
you know,
having this youthful biology of this,
we can apply some of these new technologies.
So I have my 40 year old cells banked and I'm 42.
And,
um,
it would be very difficult for me to get 40 year old cells,
my own 40 year old cells now unless they were not in Franklin,
Massachusetts.
Um,
and,
and so by doing that,
we kind of create this,
uh,
asset that we can work upon and we can,
we can draw upon.
And so I think we'll be able to accelerate the end,
the,
the application of some of these technologies that are in the pipeline by doing
what we're doing.
That's part of it also,
to be honest,
I think that by,
by finding people that are interested in,
in,
in taking action now,
um,
about their future health,
it kind of reminded that way.
They're there for leaning.
That we also create a kind of a cultural,
you know,
a chef.
We get a community of people that are just thinking about themselves in their
health a little bit differently.
And I think that's going to be important because we have a big transition
culturally,
if for that's going to come with this technological transition.
So what's going to happen is we're going to move to health maintenance and we a
fermilabs.
That's our job.
That's our goal,
is to like precipitate this,
make this happen faster,
do what we can.
Um,
and what's going to come with it is a change in the way we think about ourselves
and the way we think about aging.
I think in a couple of generations you're gonna have kids and they're,
you look at this picture and they'll say,
why does everybody decided have white hair?
And why are they and why are they sitting in chairs with wheels?
Um,
and,
and you know,
it's,
it's truly going to change who we are.
Um,
and I think,
I think for the better because this is not great.
Um,
so thank you very much for coming.
I appreciate it.
Do
you have a question?
Thanks so much,
mark.
We had a few questions submitted ahead of time on the dory,
but if there are live questions,
we also have microphones here.
Go ahead and ask them.
I have a knife right here.
Okay.
All right.
Go.
18 years ago I wrote a screenplay based on multiple sources,
saying that people like Henry Kissinger,
uh,
we're um,
purchasing fetal tissue from multiple sources where it's available.
As we've seen with planned parenthood,
there's multiple places and um,
intravenously ingesting it.
So basically you have a cannibalism of the young.
What keeps this going in that direction?
Well,
hopefully it is the difference in immunity.
I'll slow it down and distill this down to you.
Notice how he never ages.
He's just kissing her.
So I don't know what his,
his,
his story is,
but he's amazing.
Yeah,
he's,
they always looks the same for you.
Go back to those old pictures and compare to the new pictures.
It's like,
wow,
that's guy.
Was that guy that comp did Saint Germain?
Maybe he's at two.
He is.
Um,
so yeah,
I,
I think if we
step one step one is,
is,
is I,
I believe is this,
that,
that we can draw on her own biology and,
and there are ways,
you know,
you might've heard of,
the,
the young blood effect.
Um,
there's a couple,
there's actually,
there's a trial called the Ambrosia trial where they're taking young plasma from
patients,
donors and people are treating themselves to see if they can have an effect upon
their,
their aging biomarkers,
say their biology and rejuvenate it.
And,
um,
interestingly,
so the bone marrow,
especially the Mesenchymal stem cell they was talking about,
it releases a lot of soluble factors into the blood that affect the,
the state of the body.
And we're actually pretty confident that part of the younger blood effect that
you see.
Then this happens.
Like what they'll do is they'll take an old mouse and I like the young mouse.
It's really grizzly.
They'll,
they'll put their vascular there,
their circulatory systems together and um,
but they'll see rejuvenation and the old mouse,
um,
from this,
this young blood donation.
And,
uh,
the bone marrow gives birth the most of what's in the blood.
Um,
and we do think that if you can re re juvenate the bone marrow,
you're going to get kind of an autologous Youngblood effect.
Um,
so yeah,
I guess that's a,
that is a tough question.
What's gonna stop us from,
well,
I think I hopefully a lot of things to stop us from doing other things like
that.
The young glide,
oh,
oh gosh.
I don't know.
I have spoken to some people that I think there's some people that have done
some kind of crazy stuff I don't know about against being Henry Kissinger.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I'll say this young cells I've done in the lab,
I've taken the soluble factors from young cells and treated old cells with them
and you do see some kind of rejuvenate effect.
There's,
there's a way that that young biology can,
can kind of encourage all biology to,
to act a little more young,
but can't.
Yeah.
Specifically.
So I've got it.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah,
I was just wondering if,
if you could comment on how you think basic human habits,
like what we eat,
exercise,
sex even I've heard,
I've heard it's like having orgasms,
uh,
having many orgasms like makes you live shorter.
I've heard that.
Ah,
I duNno.
I've seen,
could you just comment on this and just give advice and what you should and
should not do live longer.
Did you also grow up Catholic?
I kid,
I kid.
Um,
no.
So,
um,
I think there are some,
there's evidence for Keller restriction and a lot of animals even up to a rhesus
monkeys,
there's pretty good evidence.
Um,
it's difficult in humans to see longevity.
That takes a long time.
Um,
there was some evidence though that low calorie restriction,
so just not over eating and keeping you too,
you know,
I'm not a nutritionist,
but a lot of those,
a moving target,
nutritional guidance and um,
there is evidence from,
you know,
flatworms all the way up to the rhesus monkey that if you keep your calorie
restriction at about two thirds of what normally people they would normally eat
if they're just able to get food.
Um,
and that seems to have some benefit.
and that was actually something that I,
I keep my calories down on diet and exercise.
That's,
yeah.
Um,
and there's actually been a lot of studies using mice and exercising them and
looking at,
at,
at that effect upon their,
their health span is generally when you affect better,
not overall lifespan is much,
but health span,
it seems that once you get to the,
to the,
um,
you know,
a hundred and so your point genetics really starts to take over into determine
who's going to be around,
who's not.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I think it's interesting.
I think it's a very interesting question.
I didn't mention this,
but,
so this is something we use mice,
right?
And rats and we,
because their biology so similar,
but a mouse or rat lives two years if their biology so similar,
why do they live two years?
Um,
and that begs the question is,
is this decline,
uh,
partially programmatic.
Um,
and can we play with that?
I have a five year old daughter,
uh,
she seems to be growing up rather than old right now.
Um,
and she's got a biology very similar to mine.
What is that?
When is,
you know,
and,
and is there some kind of,
are these mechanisms that we can play with at that switching point?
So,
yeah,
I guess I went hope younger freshman.
So,
um,
my question is fundamentally what is aging?
Is there some sort of counter in the cell that just accumulates in number of
cell divisions?
Or is there like a,
a number of cell divisions?
Each cell has which case he gets tied into,
cleaned up by the immune system.
Like,
yeah,
I think that question is not answered.
It settled.
But,
um,
there are things that,
you know,
divisions in the cell,
every division,
you know,
we'll risk some kind of error so that you can begin to build up an error.
Um,
we have certain things that our cells do,
they generate garbage and then they will throw the garbage out and incinerated,
but sometimes some garbage is sticky and it builds up.
Um,
so sometimes it,
and it correlates all the time,
but you know,
our journey or journeys around the sun,
but like it's,
it's,
it's not driven by that.
Um,
it just relates to it and there's ways you can play with the biology and you
can,
um,
get it to relate less to time.
Um,
so yeah,
there's an interesting,
so there's a thing called the Hayflick limit,
which is,
you know,
um,
in cell culture,
it,
it was kind of a thought that you,
after about 60 division cells will just cease to define culture.
But that's not always the case.
So our hemopoietic stem cells in the bone marrow,
they actually divide way more than how you flick limit throughout her lifetime.
Um,
and,
and Mesenchymal stem cells are pretty sensitive to this culture conditions.
We're already finding culture conditions,
which you can,
you can divide them in and they can go further upon date.
So it's really a matter of like
not the time but how much the cell is,
is working to keep itself.
You've,
you know,
retain it and keep yourself.
You were full and there is a really interesting question of why,
how,
what is that?
Are these trigger points?
Can we,
can we tweak them?
Yeah.
All right.
Question from the Dory.
Sure.
What core scientific breakthroughs need to meet needs to be made for your
technology to actually work?
What are the downside?
Well,
ideally
we can do what happened in the mice.
Ideally we can take our young bone marrow stem cells and we can just give them
ivy like they did to ourselves.
And actually a lot of the,
when you do this,
a lot of the [inaudible] holding back to the button incorporate and ideally that
will provide or juvenile of effect and that will,
I will consider that working.
If we get increased health span,
I'll consider that working.
If we can get an increase in lifespan like that.
I like myself,
you've got this incredible,
but there are things that,
that,
um,
we could do.
So I mentioned those senescent cells,
the cells that that turn off and they kind of,
you know,
uh,
negatively impact the tissue around them.
Well,
there's,
uh,
some,
um,
work and there's actually a couple of companies here in this area that are
working on clearing out those cells.
And there's reason to believe that if we could maybe a couple of clearing that
with the rejuvenation at the same time,
we might amp it up.
So it's,
a lot of this is gonna be stepwise.
I think that there's,
there's no great wall that we need to,
we need to get over it because I think it's many,
many,
many different hurdles and we're going to knock him down.
And,
um,
you know,
I often people will talk about the escape velocity.
So if you can,
if you can teach yourself fast when you age,
you know,
then you made it.
Um,
and so I don't think there's one,
one big thing blocking us,
but countless.
Hi.
So there's kind of a classic bioethics of how you account for racial and
economic disparity when you're developing technologies like this and how do you
continue to work without leaving poor people behind?
Should rich people,
sorry,
should living longer.
It'd be something that only the rich can afford to do and have.
And how do you balance that as you develop your own company?
Definitely.
Um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
I came,
I,
you know,
I came from a middle class family and like we had,
middle class health care,
I think.
So it depends.
A lot of these tech,
a lot of technologies are available so people can pay for him first,
right?
Even cell phones or whatnot.
Um,
and that's going to be the case here.
Uh,
the,
the funding is not set up like I spared the healthcare system's not set up to
deliver these technologies aggressively to the greater population.
They need to be proven and in order to be proven,
and you people were willing to take a risk and it's going to be a private
sector,
um,
but they better funnel down.
They have to funnel down.
I mean,
that's the point.
Um,
I,
I think that,
you know,
and,
and I just,
this year,
I,
I'm just philosophical thing.
I think everything should funnel it on.
Otherwise you've disrupted,
you're gonna have,
you're gonna you're,
you're,
you're going to create a situation that's some title,
um,
everybody,
you know,
should have access.
[inaudible] and,
um,
but,
but the,
it's going to be the people,
the,
the people that are willing to take the risk on this art can be private,
you know,
our private.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
I think it's interesting though,
so once you increase the lifespan of people,
you drastically decreased the number of children they have.
And,
and,
and as,
as in developing countries,
it changes the economics pretty drastically,
that once the economic situation is such that,
um,
that,
that they,
that they're doing better than that,
then you tend to have less children.
And I think it'll be interesting to see if that's what happens.
If we,
I think one thing that's interesting about this is if we're living longer,
we're going to think longer term and something maybe like global
warming is an issue that,
you know,
if you're going to be there,
going to think about it,
um,
you're going to,
you're thinking about the different way.
I'm fine.
Yeah,
I think it remains to be seen,
but I do think it's,
pardon?
Right.
Another question from the door?
Nope.
Have one question back here.
Okay.
Actually I have two quick questions.
So the first is for those of us considering to a bank stem cells with you guys,
um,
you know,
a lot of us would want to keep them around for 30,
40,
50 years.
And since you guys are a startup,
how do we,
how do we know that still there,
right question.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
so we are,
we've actually had been searching for an insurance company that will basically
take us like,
so if we go out of business while we get a premium,
they don't cover the costs with rest of life,
but we actually charge like a,
so what we do is we've,
the way we're working on right now as there as an annual storage fee and,
and we've hit parity now that what the,
our clients are paying the fee covers the cost.
And so,
um,
we're looking to create a mechanism where we'll spin it off.
So if for some reason we crashed and burned as,
you know,
as a startup,
we would still have this,
this entity that everybody paid into and they have their cells going in there.
Uh,
that still,
I mean,
still the storage,
they're stored there.
Um,
my cells are in there,
my wife sells her in there and it's important to us that we're going to keep
doing this to keep them there.
Um,
but it's a good question.
I'm trying to,
if anybody knows,
a,
an insurance company wants to write us a new kind of premium,
let me know a new kind of plan.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's something that we absolutely are trying to cover and that's,
that's how we're doing it approaching right now.
Um,
we've had people ask if they're all,
they're all Massachusetts,
there's,
or there's an FDA group,
like I'm compliant by repository,
but a lot of people said,
well,
I want my cell phone actually both coasts.
Like I just want them in Massachusetts.
Great.
So quick question was,
um,
I know you guys have all been doing this for about a year,
but have you been able to successfully free someone's stem cells and then thaw
them and then actually put them to use?
Well,
not put them to use?
Um,
yeah.
So to put them into use and the F in the US,
we have to be part of a FDA registered clinical trial.
Um,
but yeah,
we've,
we've grown them in,
we freeze them,
we started them.
Um,
I,
I've,
I've grown my own,
um,
to,
I,
I have more outside me then inside of me just,
you know,
as a matter of experiment.
But um,
but yeah,
we,
yeah,
yeah.
It's actually the,
the technology like that reviewer said it doesn't use enough technology.
It's pretty simple.
It's tough.
A recent experiment extended the lifespan of older mice by 10 to 15%,
but implementing implanting neural stem cells into the hypothalamus can be MSC
is be induced to differentiate into neural stem cells.
Great Question Dan.
So,
um,
yeah,
so
some people will tell you yes,
we tried it a lot.
A lot of people tried it and they,
we we didn't um,
uh,
you're trying to get to a,
a different germ layer of cells,
but um,
we've seen them express neural proteins,
we've seen them fuse with normal cells but not actually become functional neuro
cells.
However,
that there was a study recently,
just last week I think about the hypothalamus and this was really interesting.
Yeah.
So they,
they found that my clearing the stem cells in the hypothalamus,
they make the animals age more quickly by by re buy re,
re,
uh,
juvenate and those cells,
they could actually expand the lifespan of the mice.
And that's the hypothalamus is fascinating.
Um,
I,
one thing I am interested,
so the,
the Mesenchymal stem cell has a power effect,
powerful effect on these inflammatory cells in the brain called the Microglia.
And it's one reason why we were interested in them and stroke and traumatic
brain injury because you get microglia these inflammatory,
these macrophage cells and they actually will start to call his death of neural
stem cells.
And so,
um,
we're interested in whether or not young MSC is.
So one of the reasons that the hypothalamus degrades over time as you get this
burden of micro glial cells in the hypothalamus.
So we're interested,
can these cells be used to actually reduce that burden?
So yeah,
that's a good question.
So,
um,
if you increase the lifespan of many,
many people,
if this becomes successful and widespread,
then a problem for overpopulation is going to get a lot of us.
Do you have any thoughts on how are we going to deal with this?
Yeah,
me personally,
no,
but I wonder,
I do wonder at that where we have fewer children,
um,
or not.
And um,
but that's a lot.
There's a lot in that,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
Mars.
Yeah.
I mean maybe we'll,
um,
I mean the trip won't be such a big deal.
Right.
Um,
and,
and I don't know.
I mean,
the thing is I think what we need to think about,
cause this is gonna Happen,
um,
like,
and I think we have to think about is not whether or not we should do it
because,
uh,
I don't think we're going to reach consensus on whether or not we should do it.
I think what we can do is we can talk about,
well,
when it happens,
how do we deal with it?
And we've talked about that.
Um,
and,
and so we have the best outcomes.
Yeah.
Oh,
we have time for two more questions.
Okay.
So thanks for answering my hackathon question.
As a follow up,
how feasible would it be to extract a neural stem cells?
Ha.
Um,
yeah,
it's difficult.
Um,
we are not credentialing urologists at the time.
and that procedure is a lot more invasive.
Um,
do you want to say,
so this guy has got this tee shirt here,
which there's only one way you can get this tee shirt.
I asked him.
It's okay.
Let me say it for the camera.
I asked him beforehand.
Otherwise that's a HIPAA violation.
Yeah.
There's only one way to get that tee shirt.
Um,
you want your neural stem cells out?
We,
we'll talk.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
yeah,
that's,
that's it's,
so there are,
there's a thing called induced pluripotency and where you can take us,
I'm not as stem cell.
Even sometimes when you can,
you can express some jeans and you can get it to have a stem like state.
Um,
and then you can take that and make it a neural stem cell.
However,
right now we're not very good at it.
The way that we express the genes is not very subtle.
Um,
and those more often than not self Drusen,
that way we'll turn into what we call a teratoma kind of uncontrolled.
They don't behave unlike stem cells when they should be unlike some and,
but the the,
but that is one of the technologies we're getting better at.
So,
um,
when we do get to that point,
I'm having youthful cells that are on damage.
Um,
especially if they're multipotent you don't have to go as far to get them there.
So that's one way that might be addressed rather than going into your brain.
Right.
So a height,
so I have the two questions,
a short one,
long,
one short one first.
Um,
when you extract stem cells,
uh,
women that have an effect on the organism,
much like you keep them in,
then it helps you afterwards when we actually hoped you dry them.
So yeah,
we take
very little.
So for a bone marrow transplant,
if you do it by the methods that which we are going aspiration,
they're talking,
they'll take,
it's about 800 milliliter cc's of bone marrow.
We take about 60 CCS.
So that's,
you know,
just take 10%.
It's about 2% of your overall bone marrow blood making bone marrow.
So very few of your cells actually have to divide replacements,
most laws.
Um,
and it's kind of like donating blood.
It's often considered advanced blood drawn.
It's not okay.
Um,
yeah.
and so no.
Okay.
And the long one is a short,
you've heard of Aubrey de grey,
the guy with the longevity escape velocity and all that and his latest idea to
cure cancer is to,
uh,
re removed telomerase from the genome essentially.
Like you cannot make long race and make stem cells that have it.
Yeah.
I love,
and then just get a shot of those through every so often.
Right,
right.
I mean,
think of the idea.
I think it's one of the things through delivery is going to be tough.
I really think the,
you know,
thinking about things in that way,
it's really cool.
You use this completely counterintuitive approach.
Um,
but I do think it's complicated by getting the cells to the right place and,
and then,
gosh,
that's,
you're going to come back,
come back,
come back.
Also,
um,
the,
the telomeres themselves and their rate of change of the telomeres,
it actually is,
is a signal for other expression of other genes in the cells.
And so I think that if you did that,
if you were just turning until the race off,
that you might have these effects,
you might induce effects at that based on regulatory mechanisms that are looking
at them and look into the rate of change.
Um,
that's,
that's one of those things.
It's,
it's,
you know,
whenever you're,
uh,
dealing with biology as they,
you want to do one thing,
you want to effect one thing and then you find out it was a stool.
It was,
I'd like to know if it was another stool they didn't,
weren't aware of.
And,
and um,
yeah.
So I think that,
but I think it's a very,
you know,
it's a cool approach and I,
yeah,
but actually I had to talk him about it.
Yeah.
Well,
thanks so much.
Thanks so much everyone for joining us and thanks mark for talking to Google.